HBO might be best known for producing
hit series like The Sopranos Westworld
and Game of Thrones but the pay cable
network has consistently churned out
quality television series far beyond as
most popular programs some of its finest
works have been forgotten by time even
though many of them still hold up if
you're looking for another old show
stream to fill the void until all those
dragons and the theme park hosts are
back in action again here are some of
the hidden HBO gems you should take a
look at Angels in America when it
debuted back in 2003 Angels in America
was a unique television experience and
it still is the six-part miniseries was
adapted from the two-part play by Tony
Kushner and tells the story of the AIDS
crisis through a magical realist lens
the miniseries centers on a gay man
whose partner abandons him after he's
diagnosed with AIDS as if that weren't
enough of a burden
he's also visited by an angel who
declares him a prophet the series
features an all-star cast that includes
Justin Kirk Ben Shenkman mary-louise
Parker Emma Thompson Al Pacino Patrick
Wilson Jeffrey Wright and Meryl Streep
in multiple roles including a brief
stint as a mail rabbi bored to death
there's nothing else quite like bored to
death a comedy that began in 2009 and
ran for three seasons it stars Jason
Schwartzman as a writer who decides to
distract himself from the daunting
prospect of his next novel by becoming
an unlicensed private detective Zach
Galifianakis plays his best friend a
comic book artist and Ted Danson appears
as an older friend and mentor who edits
an acclaimed magazine where Jonathan
writes oh my god I have completely
failed at the most important thing in
life Jonathan doesn't take his detective
work all that seriously having learned
everything he knows from Raymond
Chandler novels but as the series goes
on he gets involved in some surprisingly
dire situations this show isn't for
everybody
but if you're a mystery fan or enjoy
comedies about overeducated stoners
failing at things it might be for you
carnival HBO is known for its ambitious
original programming and carnival is a
show that aims incredibly high but never
got fully off the ground however that
doesn't mean it's not an interesting
oddity worth of watch
especially for fans of dark fantasy set
in the Dust Bowl of the mid 1930s
carnival is about a traveling carnival
but it's also a supernatural battle
between destined avatars of good and
evil when the series started in 2003
creator Daniel Nava intended it to tell
one complex story over the course of six
seasons and fortunately HBO only ended
up giving it to so most of that story
remains untold but come back this Lisa
Kudrow comedy run for just two seasons
but spanned the nine years the former
friend star stars with a shallow and
self-centered 90s sitcom star trying to
make a return to the fame game with the
new sitcom and reality show unlike
Phoebe Buffay Kudrow's new character is
obsessed with her own image but
constantly fails to make a good
impression
despite her and likeability the series
also effectively satirizes a sexist and
ageist entertainment industry which has
little room and even less respect for a
middle-aged sitcom actress the comeback
was initially canceled after its first
season in 2005 but in the years to come
its reputation grow in 2014 the show was
unexpectedly revived for a second season
the comeback was an insightful and
biting satire from the start but the
long arc enabled by such an unusual
break between seasons makes it something
truly special we can only hope it
returns for a third season in 2023 five
days this 2007 co-production with the
BBC is a mystery series that also serves
as an effective emotional drama each of
the five episodes tells the story of one
day in the investigation of the
mysterious disappearance of a younger
mother and her two children spanning
from the very first day to the 79th day
of the search for truth this method not
only allows the audience to see how much
changes as the days weeks and months
roll on but it also introduces a
riveting performance by future Selma Sir
David Oh yellow Lowe who appears as a
father whose family vanishes parades end
Benedict Cumberbatch fans will
definitely want to check out parades end
which centers on three people whose
lives in Britain are upended by World
War one opposite Rebecca Hall and
Adelaide Clemens Cumberbatch plays a
rich conservative status dish
who is badly injured in the war the
entire five episode miniseries was
written by acclaimed playwright Tom
Stoppard and directed by Susannah white
and serves as a formidable British
period drama togetherness titans of
indie filmmaking brothers Mark and Jay
Duplass collaborated with Steve's assess
to create the plot for togetherness
which premiered in 2015 and run for two
seasons
mark Duplass plays Brett Pierson a Los
Angeles sound editor with a wife and two
kids melanie lynskey plays his wife
Michelle who's concerned about their
romantic life amanda peet is Tina Morris
Michelle's sister who unexpectedly moves
him with their family after splitting up
with her boyfriend in Houston zissis
appears as Alex Bret's best friend who
also moves in when his acting career
isn't going well
as anyone who's watched a television
show could guess an attraction develops
between Tina and Alex which gets
increasingly complicated as the show
goes on in other ways our starting with
the dialogue the show is quite unlike
the usual TV comedies and as two seasons
are well worth a look thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]